[Musique]
salut et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
vidéo déduire la vie de six personnes
donc c'est l'épisode 3 alors dans des
conditions un peu particulières je vous
en reparle et parce qu'on est dans un
théâtre mais il y aura pas de public
mais pourtant il y aura quand même si
personne ça vous allez voir comment on
s'est organisé pour ça c'est juste un
peu ours et si vous n'avez pas vu les
épisodes précédents qui sera en lien
dans la description dites vous que c'est
un truc un peu à la sherlock holmes je
vais avoir six inconnus devant moi et
faut que je le devine ou déduisent des
choses sur eux
loïc génériques atteindrait arrête
arrête stop c'est le générique loïc dans
quelques secondes
c'est pas maintenant je voulais juste
faire voir un peu la configuration donc
on est sur la scène du théâtre de
l'apollo théâtre et je vais avoir des
gens d'entre vous que j'ai sélectionné
sur instagram avec un petit
questionnaire qui vont être ici un petit
peu partout autour de moi dans des
écrans et je vais avoir aussi ses écrans
devant moi ce qui va me permet de
pouvoir les voir les analyses et même de
les entendre en même temps et c'est ça
qui est un peu ouvre comme concept en
est sûre la step de dessus du game du
live en interaction pour faire du
mentalisme j'espère que ça va vous
plaire loïc maintenant génériques
[Musique]
mais je vais commencer peut-être avec
peut-être avec mathieu tient bon soir
mathieu ça va bien bon bah en fait je
retire ce que j'ai dit au niveau de la
pression vous l'avez quand même ok ces
collisions vision ouais c'est vrai
hockey mathieu mathieu tu dois avoir tu
dois avoir 26 ou 27 ans et sa 26 26 ans
ok je vois ton anti char blessés d'en
déduire des choses mais pas grand chose
je vais te regarder aussi un petit peu
ici de ce côté là qu'est ce que je peux
dire sur toi mathieu d'intéressant
qu'est-ce qui pourrait être cool mathieu
mathieu
alors soit et pas sportif soit tu fais
du cardio plutôt cardio la course à pied
course à pied auquel cool ça c'était le
premier risque est ce que c'est le
risque de vexer une personne c'est ça
qui est bien non je j'ai le même corps
que toi mais ok ça c'est en fait les
corps fin en vrai et qu'on a l'air un
peu dynamique ce sont des personnes qui
font de la course ou ce genre de choses
ok est ce que tu peux me dire mathieu
deux qualités que tu penses avoir et
deux défauts que tu penses avoir uni
persévérant persévérant d'accord et
courageux et courageux d'accord
maintenant tes qualités et des défauts
et qualités je suis très timide
on ne dirait pas forcément ok ça c'est
assez intéressant d'accord et deuxième
c'est pas évident de faire cet exercice
ouais ok me donne me donne pas de
deuxième défaut je veux dire pourquoi
parce que si tu cherches trop longtemps
tu vas me donner un pan de faire plaisir
mais c'était les réponses les plus
spontané qui m'intéressait ton
comportement à ce moment là d'accord ok
du coup tu dois être de fin d'année jeu
direct et capricorne est ce que c'est
correct
tout à fait oui on a une première
réussite
c'est peut-être la dernière alors
applaudi la de chez toi je te le dis
c'est pas
mais n'hésitez pas dans les écrans 1
soit content de ça parce que moi je suis
content de ça ok c'est la timidité qui
m'a débloqué ok alors petite parenthèse
sur les signes astrologiques ya plein de
vidéos nous essaie de détruire les
signes astrologiques où je le fais aussi
un spectacle
des fois j'ai bon des fois je me trompe
évidemment dans la majorité des cas j'ai
bon pourquoi et comment il ya comme un
truc à signaler c'est que je n'ai pas de
croyance particulière envers
l'astrologie et envers les signes
astrologiques je pense pas qu'il y ait
12 catégories de personnes dans le monde
ceci suivant quand est née c'est un plus
ce genre de choses par contre j'ai
trouvé plein de méthode pour déduire les
signes astrologiques et j'en ferai une
vidéo un jour de ça cette année
voilà donc abonnez vous activer la coche
comme ça vous verrez c'est une eau et
cette vidéo là elle va comporter tout un
faisceau de d'un 10 et de manière
différente pour trouver le signe
astrologique de quelqu'un on va revenir
comme si on va revenir six ans mathieu
mathieu mathieu qu'est ce qu'on peut
dire de toi mathieu est ce que tu peux
me faire voir tes mains en gros plan
comme ça lentement des bouger comme ça
s'il te plaît mathieu comme ça ok ouais
alors là ça va être très difficile pour
moi de voir si tu as de la corne sur les
mains et ce genre de chose d'aller des
longs doigts fins d'accord ok
est ce que ton environnement me dit
quelque chose
non ok je vois pas très bien comment ta
taille et tabarre non plus par contre un
casque qui est très intéressant tu es un
tee shirt
donc là je vais me baser sur des
préjugés parce qu'en fait ce que fait
sherlock holmes de base c'est se baser
sur des préjugés des expériences d'en
faire des hypothèses et les déduire ça
veut pas dire que ces préjugés sont bons
mais ça veut dire que là on est à une
époque où on dira il faut surtout pas
avoir de préjugés et où n'empêche que
pour faire dès les premières hypothèses
ça peut être intéressant de parler
l'église et du coup de tout ce que j'ai
sur toi je pense que tu travailles dans
un métier un peu tu dois être dans
l'analyse des choses peut-être derrière
un bureau ce genre de choses je ne sais
pas mais je pense que tu dois être
quelqu'un qui analyse des données et en
ressort quelque chose c'est hyper large
je sais mais est-ce que je suis sur la
bonne piste
c'est ok c'est pas mal oui je suis
boulanger donc j'analyse la lutte est en
écoute ci salue plaisir layar est ce que
tu penses que je peux deviner ou déduire
ton métier je pense pas c'est très
spécifique d'accord alors est ce que tu
peux nous le dire comme ça on va
comparer avec l'hypothèse de départ je
suis ingénieur santé sécurité
voilà donc je n'aurai jamais trouvé ça
c'est tout ce qui est représenté la
prévention des risques en milieu
industriel
ok donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que tu collecte les risques possibles tu
les analyses et tu trouve des solutions
oui pour éviter que par exemple toi tu
es un accident là sur scène d'accord on
a approché on a approché ton métier au
plus loin que je pouvais en tout cas on
a trouvé le signe astrologique
on va partir maintenant sûr
ton plus gros fantasmes ton plus gros
rêve ok je vais prendre des notes
est ce que tu pourrais me dire trois
rêves qui n'ont rien à voir avec ton
plus grand rêve monter l'everest
ok monter l'everest faire le tour du
monde
tour du monde mangeait tous les plats du
ok manger tous les plats du monde jeu le
racing peu comme pour le deuxième défaut
tout à l'heure il était tellement
déconnecté que tu viens d'en faire un
pan de faire un peu plaisir c'est cool
mais du coup ce qui m'intéresse était la
réponse immédiate réponse immédiate on
avait monté les neuf reste quelque chose
dans le sens de la hauteur et après on
avait tour du monde qui est quelque
chose où il ya un très long trajet ok et
comme notre psychologie aller comme
aller le cerveau il est associatif et
comparatifs
je sais que ton plus grand rêve il est
forcément liée à de la hauteur est
forcément lié à une grande distance
est-ce que juste oui ou non j'ai juste
oui c'est peut-être peut-être monter
dans une fusée ou un truc comme ça c'est
quoi ton plus grand rêve aller dans
l'espace aller dans l'espace on est pas
mal on est à côté je vous fait rêver
rentrer moi j'adorerais 1 c'est être en
apesanteur s'est attendri nathan
pourquoi tu as qui essaient de la tête
quand je parlais de re d'aller dans
l'espace ses intérêts aussi partie
d'accord ok on va peut-être passer à
florence tient florence juste à côté
parce que florence
je t'avoue que j'ai une théorie sur ton
métier depuis le départ pour moi tu es
soit coiffeuse pro assez moderne soit
maquilleuse pro assez moderne aussi est
ce que tu es l'un des deux oui oui et tu
es coiffeuses et maquilleuses du coup
voilà c'était clairement stéréotypé par
rapport non pas au fait qu'il soit
maquiller coiffer mais par rapport aux
soins qu'ils aient pris assez
particulier et où tu te dis c'est pas
quelqu'un qui pour une vidéo parce
qu'elle va passer dans un écran va se
maquiller se coiffer comme ça en fait
est ce que tu peux me dire les cinq
premiers signes astrologiques qui passe
par la tête s'il te plaît capricorne
poisson oui et je n'ai rien donc un
autre il y en a ok bah stop c'est c'est
très bien ça ça veut dire que tu viens
de me dire les quatre qui te viennent
que tu n'es pas et ça c'est petit
sourire ça veut dire oui c'est vrai ok
est ce que tu peux me dire s'il te plaît
allez on va dire
scorpion de poissons verso est ce que tu
peux dire ça scorpion poisson verse
c'est fou le verso de donne à sourire
c'est incroyable
d merci c'est cool de florence ont un
truc tu étais maquilleuse à toi que tu
étais verso nathan a réagi à vers sauter
verser aussi aux mails ou non titan plus
grand rêve comment je peux essayer de
trouver et de déduire ça ok je ne posais
pas de questions et tu vas jamais me
répondre mais par contre doit répondre
dans ta tête s'il te plaît d'accord ok
ok est ce que ton rêve et quelque chose
d'accessible de réalisable plus calés
dans l'espace tu vois ok on est sur un
oui d'accord
l'agacement ça veut dire que j'ai raison
ok ok est ce que ton rêve est liée à la
notion d'achat parce que il faut
posséder quelque chose non tu vois même
pas de quoi je parle donc c'est
intéressant est ce que ton rêve est liée
à la notion de déplacement comme aller
dans l'espace où aller quelque part oui
oui c'est dur un diable et le poker fait
se défend le 10 mai le mentaliste ça
marche comme en bas juste regard de
l'autre en fait tu le regardes n'étale
pas dûment temps qu'il fait ok donc
c'est d'aller quelque part dans le monde
là répond moi avec ta voix en entier
c'est vraiment d'aller un endroit
spécifique du monde où c'est un tour du
monde
non c'est un nombre spécifique un
endroit spécifique ok je peux essayer de
trouver
est ce que tu peux me citer les cinq
continents europe amérique du nord
amérique du sud
océanie est ok donc amérique du sud
c'est là on a eu blocage et la
libération derrière donc c'est un
amérique du sud c'est correct
non pas du tout c'est juste que je n'ai
vu aucun dommage
y'a trop témoin 700 personnes logées qui
va nécessairement d'âge ok du coup c'est
l'asie qui m'a fait ni à la fin broc et
donc ça doit être asie alors ouais ok
will will il ya quelque chose qui
m'intéresse avec toi depuis tout à
l'heure c'est a tenu et c'est la manière
dont tu m'as répondu bonjour tout à
l'heure est ce que tu peux me dire
comment tu vas mathieu en ce moment oui
louis excusez moi wild dit comment tu
vas will en ce moment ok tu sais que en
faisant ça il vient de me confirmer
quelque chose vraiment c'est à dire que
la manière que tu as tu exprimes et de
porter à voit la manière de tenir et la
manière de faire les plaques comme ça je
me demande si tu fais pas un métier soit
sur scène soit un petit peu comme nathan
tout à l'heure barman avec un vrai
contact public
mais quand même dans la présidence il ya
un truc de mecs de seine est ce que
c'est correct
pas du tout pas du tout écoutez
maintenant je vous met la vidéo qui est
sorti aujourd'hui puis je vais aller
parler et pour le loisir tu fais pas de
spectacle non plus tu fais pas de scène
non non d'accord ok non mais ça m'arrive
d'être complètement à côté mais je te
recommande de faire de la scène un jour
we will will je me dis faut que je
trouve un truc sur toi quand même de ce
que tu fais dans la vie ou quelque chose
comme ça du coup est ce que tu peux me
faire voir tes mains s'il te plaît en
gros plan s'il te plaît hockey acih un
peu plus bornes quand même fait voir les
laisons le s'il te plaît ouais c'est
vraiment celle où s'il ya quelqu'un qui
vient de ce côté mais ce n'est que
maintenant il mais c'est quoi c'est
ruffier serre où j ai été voir juste le
bout des doigts le bout des doigts le
bout des doigts
ouais c'est pas mal et la paume vraiment
la paume des mains la paume des mains
toi ça c'est sa ligne de vie c'est pas
bon vous voyez les armes pour éclater
tout ça ok c'est bon j'ai tout ce qu'il
me faut ok donc tu fais un métier manuel
tu fais un métier manuel qui ne s'agit
pas les dents donc c'est pas de la
mécanique ou ce genre de choses
travail du bois ça passe mais ça tu fais
quoi
sculpteur menuisière truc comme ça du
gier menuisier ébéniste menuisier
ébéniste
ok alors tu vois j'ai peut-être pas
trouvé que tu étais sur scène mais je me
suis rattrapé parce que tu es quand même
difficile maintenant c'est parce que
c'est pas moi et c'est quoi ton plus
grand rêve parce que je vois le leur qui
tourne et il faut vraiment que que je
termine cette séquence là c'était quoi
ton plus grand rêve donc je sais que
c'est effectivement t'es pas loin
c'était de monter sur scène donc plus
grand rêve c'est de monter sur scène
pour faire quoi de la musique où
l'humour ou non
[Musique]
du coup tu sais que mon échec je suis en
train de me dire c'est un succès je vais
je vais vite fait allez d'hypothèses en
hypothèse le plus rapidement possible
baptiste l'hypothèse je sais que ce
n'était pas sain c'est de faire partie
des target mais jenny potez comme quoi
j'ai dit lui et les soies flic soit dans
l'armée est ce que j'ai bon pas un congo
et de suie gendarmes
ob oui c'est vrai les charlene est ce
que tu peux me dire la première citation
qui devient l'esprit dans ta vie oh
c'est pas intéressant ok donc en vrai
quand tu demandes d'une citation comme
ça à quelqu'un ou quand on entend
quelqu'un dans la vie courante faire une
citation s'adapte on apprend beaucoup
sur lui ou sur elle parce que une
situation citées ça veut dire que ça a
du sens pour toi énormément donc ça veut
dire que tu as forcément un cheminement
dans le développement personnel dans la
remise en question et une sensibilité
aux questions sociétales et
environnementales
est-ce que jusque là j'ai bon exactement
ok bon jeu direct à peut-être 28 29 ans
28 ans c'est ce que je dis 28 ans je
sais pas dans quoi tu travailles mais je
pense que tu travailles à ton compte est
ce que j'ai bon ou pas ça sent le monde
oui oui ils ont bu un peu non
c'est un louis blasi pourquoi dont on
peut dérouler c'est pas très grave en
fait ça va anticiper sur mon rêve
en fait c'est pour ça d'accord c'est un
rêve qui est à toi ok ok et du coup ce
genre de sensibilité là habituellement
la tribu au cancer est ce que tu cancer
oui je fais attention à moi même marie
je pense avoir une zone de testing en
fait il ya un truc
en général je reconnais les personnes du
même signe que moi d'accord alors ça
c'est plus que l'hypothèse c'est un peu
de l'intuition je sais pas ce que mon
cerveau repères qui dit en ahl à peu
près la même codification sur le signe
mais c'était du même signe que moi ça
veut dire que tu es scorpions si tu n'es
pas scorpions sade veut dire qu'il
faudrait que tu changes de signes est ce
que tu es oui on a un deuxième single
rapahël ok merci beaucoup ramé wild
thing facile je pense à trouver si je
dis pas de bêtises cherche à voir le
poker fait ce que j'ai bon que j'ai tort
tant que j'ai pas dit mais les personnes
comme ça avenante qui sont vers l'avant
je l' ai déjà dit dans la vidéo
précédente d'ailleurs de détruire la vie
de six personnes qui ont cette voie là
qui porte qui ont une crinière quoi
qu'il arrive en général ce sont des
lions est ce que tu es lyon alix quand
je te vois en déduction assez classique
assez basique et de comment tu te
comportes comme en décoiffer
comment tu es habillée de comment tu
souris comment tu réagis depuis tout à
l'heure que je fais des blagues je
dirais que tu fais un travail peut-être
du travail dans un bureau dans une
rédaction dans un open space mais que tu
as pas un métier de contact avec
l'extérieur c'est plus un métier où faut
s'organiser répondent à des choses
vraies les mails des coups de fil des
relations avec des personnes mais voilà
un travail plutôt de bureaux est ce que
c'est correct
oui c'est quoi ton métier exact son
signe astrologique ça pourrait être quoi
j'ai deux petites hypothèse pour
l'instant entre balances et poissons ok
je pense que j'ai le bon dans l'un des
deux parce que tu a frisé surpoids sont
des poissons
oui ok ben voila et bien c'est bon on
attend sinon ça veut dire qu'on a fait
tous les signes je vais essayer de
trouver ton plus grand rêve
ok on va faire comme on a fait tout à
l'heure et on finira cette vidéo là avec
ça est ce que tu peux me dire trois
choses qui n'ont rien à voir avec ton
plus grand raid s'il te plaît plongée
aux caraïbes
plongez hockey faire du saut à
l'élastique saut à l'élastique
ok allez visiter la muraille de chine
plongée c'est intéressant parce que ces
deux-là sensations fortes c'est un
changement d'environnement
si jamais vous voulez voir ce que
j'écris c'est lisible voilà je sache et
le cd note pour moi soit l'élastique
changement d'environnement sensations
fortes
également quoique plongée il ya quand
même notion de déplacement
je me demande si ton plus grand accès
pas de sauter en parachute est ce que
c'est correct on n'est pas loin on n'est
pas loin
adacore sauter sans parachute c'est
dangereux des mains non ces abats de
piloter un avion peut-être piloter un
avion hockey et c'est très cool ça est
bien assise ainsi sachez cette vidéo des
déduire la vie de six personnes je sais
pas si j'ai eu autant de matches que
j'aurais voulu mais coûte je suis moins
c'est que ce que j'avais peur
merci beaucoup pour ça en tout cas merci
si le mentalisme et tout ce genre de
technique vous intéresse vous pouvez
aussi aller piocher des informations
dans mes livres je vous mets un lien
dans la description gars celui ci il ya
celui ci il ya celui ci qui a remporté
le prix babelio cette année oui je suis
très fier qui devrait vous intéresser si
non je m'appelle toujours fabien olicard
vous pouvez vous abonner à cette chaîne
pour pas rater les prochaines vidéos
dans ce style en plus l'abonnement est
gratuit donc ne vous privez pas de ça
ici je vous mets la première vidéo de
déduire la vie de six personnes ici la
deuxième qui était encore un peu
différente et moi je dis à très bientôt
ciao